let's talk about what's going over on at
the uh the white house uh because there
is this gensake woman she is the press
secretary who will soon have a job on
msnbc because the swamp protects its own
and she was asked about bill hb155
by fox news's peter ducey what about
this new law in florida at what age does
the white house think that students
should be taught about sexual
orientation and gender identity
well i would say uh first of all peter
um we have spoken to uh the don't say
gay bill in the past i believe is what
you're referring to and made clear that
uh as we look at this uh this uh this
law
what we think it's a reflection of is
politicians in florida propagating
misinformed hateful policies that do
absolutely nothing to address
the real issues i would note that
parents across the country are looking
to
you know
national state and district leaders to
support our nation's students to ensure
that
kids are treated equally in schools and
that is certainly not this is not a
reflection of that
he's a liar
there's nothing else i i need a punching
bag of the show can we get a punching
bag in the studio and for now on every
time i'm gonna curse i'm not kidding i'm
just going to punch can we get a gen
sake punching bag i want her clown
depressed face right next to me i'm not
kidding we're gonna have to custom this
i don't know where you get one can we go
to custom punchingbags.net or whatever
and i want her face right here and every
time we show a clip of her instead of
because what's the point what's the
point of me constantly commenting on her
she's lying again everything she said
was made up instead i would just punch
the clown i'm not kidding that's what
we're gonna have to do
i know you can't hit a woman you can't
hit a woman well i'll just say she's a
man that's how we're gonna have to do it
anyway she just lies everything she said
there was a lie this has nothing to do
with hate and notice she won't answer
the question the question was very clear
ducey's question was very clear what age
do you think teaching this stuff is
appropriate and she doesn't she
immediately calls it don't say gay and
she won't give an answer um here's more
from saki so if you guys oppose this law
that
bans classroom instruction about
sexual orientation and gender identity
in k-3
does white house support that kind of
classroom instruction before
kindergarten do you have examples of
schools in uh florida that are teaching
kindergarteners about sex education
good question jen are they teaching this
stuff to kids in school she specifically
says kindergartners but obviously what
we're talking about are they teaching
this to young kids in school well you're
not going to believe this one sake
in september of 2020 my daughter told me
after school she had a meeting with
school officials that was held behind
closed doors where they asked her which
restroom she wanted to use
i immediately contacted the school as
told by the guidance counselor and
assistant principal that i could not be
given any information regarding the
meeting and that by law my daughter had
to be the one to authorize my
notification of the meeting or
attendance to the meeting
in other words school officials asked my
13 year old child
her permission as to whether or not my
parental rights would be honored
after many weeks of going back and forth
with the district we learned the middle
school had created a transgender gender
non-conforming support plan with our 13
year old daughter without our knowledge
or consent
the plan was a six-page document
completed with my daughter behind closed
doors with three school officials that
included the guidance counselor the
assistant principal and a social worker
i had never met
during the meeting they asked her
questions that could have significantly
impacted her safety and her physical and
emotional well-being such as which
restroom she preferred to use and which
sex she preferred to room with on
overnight field trips
the plan also directed school staff to
use my daughter's birth name when
speaking to us her parents and to use a
different name in school with teachers
staff and students
this plan directed school staff to
conceal from us that this meeting and
plan had ever taken place okay so joking
and glibness aside for a second
the question really is
do you think that woman
is
a bad person
do you think she's a bigot or hateful or
anything like that or do you think that
she really
actually only cares about the welfare of
her child
and that she should ultimately
be the arbiter of the decisions related
to a young child that let's say her
child is having some gender identity
stuff or maybe thinks that they're gay
or whatever else and by the way there
are all sorts of phases in life and
there are people that detransition as
adults that's something that the
mainstream media won't show you
um obviously because it doesn't fit the
narrative but you know there are kids
that are in sixth grade that think that
they're bi or gay that end up not being
and then there are there are married
adults who are have two kids that
finally come to grips with their
sexuality when they're 55 and it's too
late and then they've brought all sorts
of destruction on their family and
friends and all sorts of other things
but if you watch that video if you think
that that mother
is saying what she's saying because of
hatred or bigotry or any of the pure bs
nonsense that the media and the white
house and the mayor of new york city and
the rest of these people are spewing
you're very just confused you're just
very
confused about the issue they want
parental rights dissolved they want your
children to be property of the state and
many people are willfully letting them
do it